ah
[Música]
esta gente que pasa detrás mío está
saliendo de haber despedido a diego
armando maradona aquí en la casa de
gobierno de la casa rosada en argentina
pasan unos segundos por delante de su
féretro algunos le arrojan camisetas de
argentina otros del club boca juniors o
es una especie de homenaje para su ídolo
más temprano antes del inicio de este
velatorio público la familia los amigos
la gente más cercana había tenido un
velatorio privado para diego armando
maradona para entender lo que representa
la figura podemos citar una de las
personas que más temprano salía y que
gritó diego maradona es argentina y en
algún punto eso explica bien porque el
amor hacia su figura y porque este pesar
por la partida del astro del fútbol
argentino y un amigo me gustaría citar
lo más temprano también decía cuando yo
era pequeño no quería hacer ni el hombre
araña ni superman quería ser diego
armando maradona
[Música]
la ciudad de nápoles está de luto desde
que se supo la noticia de la muerte de
maradona miles de personas han salido a
las calles de la ciudad a rendir un
último homenaje a este ídolo del fútbol
ya que fue en nápoles en donde maradona
vivió los mejores momentos de su carrera
deportiva desde que inició a jugar con
el napoli en 1984 en esa época este era
un equipo con pocas ambiciones y gracias
a maradona logró ganar los más
importantes títulos de su historia dos
títulos nacionales una copa italia una
copa europea antes de maradona jamás un
equipo del sur había ganado el
campeonato italiano maradona se
convirtió en el portavoz de las
esperanzas de la italia meridional
muchas veces despreciada por el norte
del país y así inspiró a toda una
generación de italianos que crecieron
con el mito de maradona soñaron con su
destino vibraron con cada gol y hoy
lloran dolorosamente su desaparición
[Música]
los ingleses no han podido olvidar el
famoso gol de la mano de dios' que anoto
maradona durante el encuentro contra
inglaterra en el mundial de méxico de
1986 partido histórico en el que
inglaterra fue descalificada además la
camiseta con el número 10 que portó
maradona en ese encuentro se ubica aquí
en inglaterra y pertenece al
exfutbolista inglés de la selección
nacional
steve y podría valer decenas de miles de
libras uno de los primeros en rendirle
homenaje a maradona fue el ex futbolista
gary lineker quien aseguró que el
argentino ha sido el mejor jugador de
todos los tiempos además el manchester
city guardó un minuto de silencio y su
entrenador pep guardiola aseguró que
maradona cambió para siempre y para bien
el rumbo del fútbol
[Música]